voici ce qui va changer en juin 2022 à
partir du 13 juin les personnes ayant
demandé l'ouverture d'un compte bancaire
et n'ayant pas obtenu de réponses sous
quinze jours sont redirigés
automatiquement vers une banque proche
de leur domicile le 19 juin l'assemblée
nationale sera renouvelé suite au
deuxième tour des législatives
le 22 juin les soldes d'été débuteront
et dureront quatre semaines le 30 juin
le plafond des titres restaurant aux
descendra de 38 à 10,9 euros par an il
est désormais possible de résilier son
assurance emprunteur à tout moment pour
en changer sans frais les anciens
malades du cancer ou de l'hépatite c
pourront désormais contracter un prêt
dans les mêmes conditions que le reste
de la population mais uniquement cinq
ans après leur guérison auparavant ce
droit à l'oubli était de 10 ans